- - Martine Biron, Christian
DuDufour et Alec Castonguay,
bobonsoir. C'est pas terminé au
paparti libéral du Québec. Je vs
fafais entendre Madame Anglade i
enen a ajouté une couche à props
dede Mme Montpetit en disant :
c'c'est terminé, elle n'a plus
d'd'avenir au parti libéral du
QuQuébec, elle ne pourrait pas
rereposer sa candidature. Elle
exexplique pourquoi. Je vous fas
enentendre Monsieur Arcand après
ququi a voulu calmer le jeu.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
PaParti libéral du Québec
- - Moi, comme chef, je ne
prprendrai pas de décision basée
susur un lien que j'ai avec une
pepersonne ou une autre, je vais
prprendre des décisions basées
susur les faits qu'on me donne,
babasée sur les faits qui
ararrivent. Et quand je vois
dedes faits, quand je vois qui
meme disent qu'il y a des gens
ququi ne sont pas traités
dede la manière dont ils devaiet
êêtre traités, quand je vois des
sisituations où les gens n'ont s
rereçu le respect qu'ils devrait
avavoir, je n'ai pas le choix
quque d'agir et de dire
quque c'est tolérance zéro.
- - Est-ce que Madame Montpetit
popourrait réintégrer le caucus?
- - Avec la quantité d'informatn
quque j'ai aujourd'hui,
avavec les faits qui m'ont été
prprésentés, je ne vois pas
dede quelle manière se produira.
PIPIERRE ARCAND, député, PLQ,
MoMont-Royalal - Outremont
- - On l'a déjà dit, lors du
cacaucus qui avait lieu à Orfor,
quque le Parti libéral allait
rerebondir en 2022 et j'ai
plpleinement confiance en Mme
AnAnglade. Ce sont des périodes
didifficiles, bien sûr, ce qu'on
vivit actuellement, mais moi,
jeje sais une chose : il faut
trtravailler pour la prochaine
élélection et il faut travailler
enen équipe, tout le monde
enen équipe, et c'est ce que
jeje vais m'appliquer à faire
cocomme président du caucus.
- - Martine, avec la quantité
d'd'information que j'ai
auaujourd'hui et avec les faits
ququi m'ont été présentés, je ne
vovois pas de quelle manière ele
popourrait revenir. Encore une
fofois, le processus n'a pas été
jujusqu'au bout. On ne sait pas,
ilil n'y a pas eu de rapport
inindépendant de l'Assemblée
nanationale, mais à sa face mêm,
lala chef décide que c'est trop
grgrave. C'est ce qu'on compren.
- - Et donc la carrière de Marie
MoMontpetit est terminée au pari
lilibéral du Québec tant et ausi
lolongtemps que Dominique Anglae
sesera chef de ces parties. Il y
enen a beaucoup des témoignages.
J'J'en ai eu et j'ai des collègs
ququi en ont collectcté plusieu.
IlIls sont assez faciles à
rérécupérer. Probablement que
MaMadame Anglade a eu vent, a eu
écécho de ces témoignages. Ellea
ququand même aujourd'hui gagné e
didirais la première manche de a
babataille, parce que quand mêm,
cece n'est pas n'importe qui,
MaMarie Montpetit. C'est une
prproche de Dominique Anglade.
C'C'est la première à l'avoir
apappuyé à sa course à la
didirection. Elle a joué un rôle
mamajeur dans son élection à la
ttête du parti libéral. Elle lui
a a renvoyé l'ascenseur en lui
dodonner le prestigieux
poportefeuille de la santé. C'et
unune femme de confiance. Alors
elelle met une croix sur cet alé
pourur envoyer un message clairà
seses troupes que e le harcèlemt
esest l'intimidation, elle n'en
veveut pas. Il lui reste d'autrs
ététapes à gagner. D'abord la
dedeuxième étape je pense que
c'c'est le caucus de demain. Le
memercredi, c'est le caucus
ststatutaire. Il va y avoir des
enenjeux discutés dans le cas de
M.M. Barrette.
- - Alec et Christian, elle n'a
papas... à vos yeux, elle n'a ps
dodonc le besoin d'attendre les
coconclusions d'une enquête
inindépendante pour suivre une
liligne sur l'avenir de Mme
MoMontpetit? Alex?
- - Vous savait, les chiffres st
sosouverains. Ils peuvent décidr
ququi se présentent, qui ne se
prprésente pas, qui est acceptét
OKOK ce qui ne l'est pas. Les
ininformations que Dominique
AnAnglade possède sont assez
sésérieuses pour que même si une
enenquête déroule, elle ne veut
plplus que ce soit elle qui
rereprésente les Parti libéral
dadans Maurice Richard. C'est la
prprérogative du chef qui peut
dédécider si oui ou non en vue e
cecette personne se présente aux
prprochaines élections. On dit
avavec les Parti libéral, mais n
réréalité, ça veut probablement
didire que sa carrière politique
esest terminée. Je ne vois pas n
auautre parti politique la
rérécupérer si elle est à ce pot
chchassé du Parti libéral. Pour
elelle, savez OK c'est la fin.
J'J'imagine qu'elle va s'expliqr
àà un moment donné, mais les
PaParti libéral a clairement
dédécidé que peu importe ce qui
alallait arriver, c'était trop
imimportant pour qu'elle porte s
cocouleurs du parti même aux
prprochaines élections.
- - Christian?
- - C'est le privilège de Madame
AnAnglade de prendre sa décisio.
OnOn peut se demander si le fait
ququ'elle avait l'air près de
MaMadame mon petit dans le pass,
esest-ce qu'il n'y a pas la
tetentation bien humaine d'en
memettre un peu plus chronométrr
auautrement?
IlIl y a des choses qui sortent,
onon ne dit qu'il y a beaucoup e
tétémoignages. Mais on ne sait s
ququi accusait on ne sait pas de
ququoi la personne est accusée
prprécisément. C'est de plus en
plplus comme ça. Je ne suis pasn
trtrain de défendre Mme Montpet.
JeJe n'ai aucune idée de ce
ququ'elle a fait. Il y a ce qu'n
apappelle des principes de juste
nanaturelle qu'on apprend à la
fafaculté de droit. Quand
ququelqu'un est accusé de quelqe
chchose, il faut qu'on sache de
ququoi il est accusé et il faut
ququ'on sache qu'il accuse. Je
coconstate que dans notre socié,
leles nouvelles instances qui st
liliées à des comportements
dédéplacés, des concepts de vage
nene respectent pas ses princips
nanaturels et ça me dérange.
CoComme citoyen, ça me dérange
paparce que c'est en train de se
gégénéraliser.
- - Martine, Madame Anglade doit
avavoir j'imagine l'appui du
cacaucus pour faire ce qu'elle
fafait là, donc selon vous, este
ququ'elle inscrit son autorité?
- - La déclaration des Pierre
ArArcand aujourd'hui était quand
mmême importante parce que c'est
unun ancien chef par intérim et1
dede la vieille garde. Une de ss
didifficultés à l'intérieur de n
cacaucus, c'est de faire le pont
enentre les gènes, la génération
momontante et les générations
sosortantes qui a servi notammet
sosous Jean Charrait sous Philie
Couillard est et qui sont
totoujours loyaux à ces deux
ananciens premier ministre. Made
AnAnglade veut faire une croix r
cecette période. C'est plus
didifficile pour ses plus vieux
dédéputés de lui être loyal à
DoDominique Anglade.
- - On comprend que Mme Montpett
n'n'avaient pas beaucoup d'alli,
avavait beaucoup d'adversaires
dadans le caucus.
- - Pas mal oui.
- - On verra ce que Monsieur
BaBarrette décidera de faire.
- - Je trouve que c'est un énore
tetest de leadership pour Madame
AnAnglade. Elle a été élue par
réréclamation chef du Parti
lilibéral. Elle a fait des effos
popour se rapprocher de la
mamajorité francophone mais c'et
cocomme si les Parti libéral ne
sesemble pas porteur de quelque
chchose qu'on peut identifier.
ElElle doit prouver qu'elle a le
cocoffre pour mener l'opposition
ofofficielle aux combats de la
prprochaine élection.
- - Je vais vous parler absolumt
dede l'annonce aujourd'hui, mais
nonon pas des allégements. On
rereviendra susur Noël, ce n'ess
enencore fixé. Le 15 novembre,
kakaraoké, danse, les stations e
skski seront un peu plus libres.
JeJe veux revenir et je vais vos
fafaire entendre Monsieur Dubé r
lala fameuse échéance du 15
nonovembre. C'est comme si on
avavait perdu la mémoire et qu'n
didit : il n'y a pas vraiment eu
dédéchéance. On écoute
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
etet Services sociaux, Québec
- - Tout le monde le voit comme
momoi que les chiffres n'ont pas
bobougé. Les gens qui ne sont ps
vavaccinés, on en avait un petit
pepeu moins que 14 000 qui
n'n'avaient pas réuss... reçu
auau moins une première dose.
EtEt là, aujourd'hui, à un petit
pepeu... presque trois semaines
plplus tard, on est à 12 000.
DoDonc, moi, je dis que l'aiguie
n'n'a pas suffisamment bougé.
C Ce que je vous dirai, je vais
cocontinuer les discussions
ququ'on a avec la santé publique
etet tous les intervenants.
- - C'est rare, Alec, je ne veux
papas faire de psychologie à dex
sosous, mais c'est rare qu'on vt
MoMonsieur Dubé baisser les bra.
IlIl avait presque envie de dir:
cecelle-là, ça n'a pas marché.
L'L'aiguille n'a pas bougé. On a
êêtre obligé de travailler avec
eueux, on n'a pas le choix.
- - Il n'est pas le seul. Je
rerefoule savais François Legaut
àà mon émission la semaine
dedernière qui disait : peut-ête
quque dans certains secteurs, on
vava être capable d'imposer les
vavaccinations obligatoires, mas
dadans d'autres, on ne va pas êe
cacapable. On avait commencé à
mamarcher sur la de la semaine
dedernière. Avant l'attitude de
MoMonsieur Dubé, je ne pense pas
ququ'il y a beaucoup d'espoir et
dede convaincre ceux qui ne
veveulent pas se faire vaccinerà
y y aller. En Colombie-
BrBritannique, on a mit la menae
àà exécution. Il y a trois plus
dede 3000 travailleurs de la saé
ququi vont être suspendus sans
sosolde. Dans trois mois, ils vt
totout simplement être congédié.
SiSi on ramène ça ici, c'est coe
sisi on avait six ou 7000
trtravailleurs de la santé qui
n'n'était pas vacciné et qu'on s
memettait à pied. On est encoreà
1212 ou 13 000. C'est quand même
énénorme pour un système de sané
auaussi fragile. On a
efeffectivement l'impression qun
nene sera pas capable d'y arriv.
LeLes tests routiniers trois fos
papar semaines qui sont imposée,
ququi sont là pour rester, ça va
êêtre sale rempart contre les
écéclosions dans les milieux dea
sasanté parce qu'on ne sera pas
cacapable de convaincre assez de
gegens d'aller se faire vaccine.
- - Et si vous ne voulez pas alr
vovous faire vacciner, ce ne sot
papas les propos d'aujourd'hui i
vovont faire que vous allez y
alaller, parce que vous sentez
bibien qu'une vous n'allez pas
vovous faire envoyer. Christian?
- - C'est clair que les discours
etet gouvernement à changer et
c'c'est une très bonne chose pae
ququ'on est dans la réalité. On
n'n'est pas dans le dogmatisme u
l'l'idéologie sanitaire de risqe
zézéro. Rappelons que les
QuQuébécois sont massivement
vavaccinés deux fois. On est
prpresque à 90 %. Rappelons les
chchoses qu'on ne dit pas assez,
quque c'est mieux de se faire
sosoigner par une infirmière non
vavaccinée que de ne pas se faie
sosoigner du Doubs. Les gens qui
nene sont pas vaccinés, on va lr
imimposer de tester par semaine.
LeLe gouvernement a jugé et je
pepense qu'il fait bien que le
ririsque serait plus grand que e
sese départir de ses travailleus
ququi ont jugé bon de ne pas se
fafaire vacciner. Je ne comprens
papas cette décision, ils ont
drdroit de le faire. On est renu
dadans autre chose et c'est une
trtrès bonne nouvelle.
- - Martine?
- - Monsieur Legault a dit qu'iy
avavait quand même certains
dédépartements où la vaccination
seserait obligatoire notamment
dadans les urgences. Il avait dt
: : je ne laisserai pas de pass
drdroit dans les urgences. Il
avavait parlé aussi de certaines
rérégions où c'était quand même
asassez réussi chez les
trtravailleurs de la santé. Mais
efeffectivement, les gens qui ne
sosont pas vaccinés actuellemen,
c'c'est le noyau dur et
vivisiblement, ça leur passe du
pipied par-dessus la tête d'être
sususpendu ou pas. Alors ils n't
papas l'intention de se faire
vavacciner. Et on n'a pas les
momoyens au gouvernement de
lalaisser partir des gens sans
solde, sinon le choix qu'on a à
fafaire, c'est : on pénalise ces
gegens et les patients dans
cecertains endroits ne seront ps
sosoignés et sa la situation.
- - On voit la réalité en face t
onon s'ajuste.
- - Est-ce que ce n'est pas dans
lala nature des choses à mettre
quque les gens ne peuvent pas êe
vavaccinés à 95 et 100 %? On n't
papas la Chine ici, on est le
QuQuébec.
- - Rester là, parce qu'on a
reretrouvé Michel Leblanc. On va
paparler du français et du grand
papatron d'Air Canada. Je veux
avavoir votre avis à vous...
d'd'abord, je vais parler à Micl
LeLeblanc, président et chef dea
didirection de la chambre de
cocommerce de Montréal. Un petit
momot sur les faits, ces pensées
ininapererçues, mais le gouvernt
a a dit aujourd'hui : notre
rerecommandation du télétravail,
c'c'est terminé. Donc message ax
enentreprises : vous pouvez
raramener les gens dans les tous
àà bureaux. Je vais vous montrer
dedes chiffres. C'est lent avant
quque les gens reviennent au
cecentre-ville. Vous le savez
mimieux que moi. Il y a beaucoup
dede gens qui même préfèrent
rerester à la maison. 47 % sont
enencore en télétravail. 71 % qi
sosont en télétravail souhaitent
rerester en télétravail. Est-ce
quque ça vous inquiète?
- - La réalité, c'est
ququ'effectivement, on a tous
aiaimés être en télétravail, mas
çaça ne veut pas dire cinq jours
papar semaine. Beaucoup de gense
sesentent isolés. Il y aura cete
réréalité. Les messages calant t
leles ministres gens étaient trs
imimportants. Ça devient une
ququestion d'organisation du
trtravail. Ce n'est plus une
ququestion de sécurité sanitair.
LeLes entreprises vont ramener
leleurs employés. J'attends
imimpatiemment que le gouvernemt
anannonce comme employeur ce qul
dodoit faire. Ça devrait venir
dadans les prochains jours on
esespère.
- - Si on fait une analogie avec
unun malade, est-ce que le cent-
viville se remet et qu'est-ce
ququ'il reste à faire?
- - Il y a eu un coma, il est
sosorti du coma, mais il n'est s
enencore prêt de se lever et de
sosortir du lit. C'est clair que
çaça va prendre probablement
plplusieurs mois. On incite les
gegens à revenir, on veut
cocombattre l'émotion de peur pr
unune émotion des plaisirs et ça
vava demander un effort de toute
momonde c'est clair.
- - Comme quoi? Déjà, le
gogouvernement a dit : ça y est,
leles télétravail, je ne le
rerecommande plus. Qu'est-ce
ququ'ils peuvent faire de plus?
- - Les entreprises ont déjà
plplusieurs idées pour rendre ls
lilieux de travail beaucoup plus
agagréable, mettre l'emphase sur
dedes lieux où on travail en
éqéquipe par rapport à des burex
fifixes. Ce qu'on voit beaucoup,
leles gens disent : j'ai envie e
vovoir mes collègues et les
jojournées où ils vont venir au
bubureau, ça va être des journés
dede repas collectifs, des sorts
enen groupe à la fin du travail,
leles journées de travail en
prprésence où on crée ensemble.
- - Il faut que les employeurs
sosoient afférents, dorlote les
gegens. Et leur proposer des
chchoses agréables. Ça va venir
papar les jeunes.
- - Des discours tout en anglaià
MoMontréal, ça n'a pas fait son
tetemps aussi. Monsieur Roussea,
grgrand patron d'Air Canada, va
vevenir parler chez vous demain
mimidi. Il vous signifie que tot
soson discours sera en anglais.
EsEst-ce que ça n'aurait pas été
vovotre rôle comme président et
chchef de la direction de la
chchambre de commerce dire : 100
MoMonsieur Rousseau, vous ne
popouvez pas faire ça. À la
lilimite, lisez une phrase de
rerespect, non?
- - Parcs Canada, pilier de note
écéconomie. Parcs Canada achète
dedes clients Hallandal et les
trtravailleurs chez nous. Le
nonouveau président qui en a.
AlAllait être leur. Décision..
LaLa langue commune et la langue
dede travail au Québec, c'est le
frfrançais. Il n'y a pas
d'd'ambiguïté là-dessus.
- - Donc il y a eu des va-et-vit
avavec Air Canada et vous leur
avavez dit : ça serait bien qu'l
ajajoute du français. Ces vous
mémédite?
- - J'ai dit que ça serait bient
quque ça passerait difficilement
sasa n'était pas le cas.
- - Ça fait sept ans qu'il habie
susur la rive sud : il ne peut
mmême pas lire une phrase? C'est
unun grand président. Il ne peut
papas lire une phrase en frança?
- - Je le reçois demain midi, je
vavais découvrir et comme vous e
cocontenu et la contenance. Les
memessages ont été passés. Ce
qu'on nous a répondu chez Air
CaCanada, merci beaucoup de nous
enen informer. Je pense qu'il
n'n'avait pas besoin de nous. On
leleur laisse prendre leurs
dédécisions. Je le répète encore
unune fois, je vais toujours
ininviter à ma tribune à la
chchambre de commerce les gens i
onont un impact super important
susur notre économie, sont notre
babase d'affaires et ces gens
auauront à s'expliquer. Air Cana
vava détenir les leviers très
imimportants pour Montréal dansa
prprochaine année.
- - Vous êtes qu'il n'était pas
ququestion de ne pas inviter
MoMonsieur Rousseau ou de l'aide
dedes invités parce qu'ils
n'n'allaient pas parler en
frfrançais compte tenu de
l'l'importance de son entreprise
popour Montréal?
- - Exactement et il subit ou il
susubira les éloges s'il propose
dedes choses comme il faut et de
lala bonne façon ou les
coconséquences. Ça lui appartie.
MaMais nous, nous sommes une
trtribune pour que les gens
cocomprennent quels sont les
dedestinées des grands joueurs,
leles grandes entreprises de la
rérégion.
- - Michel Leblanc, on va suivre
çaça. Peut-être que finalement,l
y y aura un peu de français. On
veverra demain, on va suivre ça
avavec vous. Merci Michel Lebla.
JeJe repose la question à mes
papanélistes, Martine, Christia,
AlAlec. Ils et qui lui a demand,
on lui a dit non. Il dit : je ne
pepeux pas ne pas inviter Air
CaCanada. Alec, qu'est-ce que tu
enen penses?
- - Est-ce qu'il pouvait ne pas
ininviter Air Canada? Je pense e
c'c'est une décision qu'il pouvt
prprendre. Il a décidé de ne pas
lele faire étant donné le poids
quque représente Air Canada dans
l'l'économie québécoise. Je pene
ququ'ils avaient le choix. Au-dà
dede ça, je pense qu'il y a un
prproblème historique Air Canada
avavec la langue française. On a
vuvu au nombre de plaintes qui t
étété déposées auprès du
cocommissaire des langues
féfédérales au fil des 30 40
dedernières années sur la
didifficulté d'être servi en
frfrançais chez Air Canada. Il a
bibien des gens qui comprennent
unune liaison Edmonton Vancouver
ouoù il y a peu de francophones,
cece n'est pas simple de recrutr
dedes agents de bord qui parle
frfrançais à l'autre b bout du .
UnUn président dont le siège
sosocial est à Montréal, en
sasachant l'historique de la
sosociété d'État avec le frança,
dadans une société d'État avavee
frfrançais, qui vit ici depuis
plplusieurs années, ne soit pas
cacapable de faire un quart ou n
titiers de son discours en
frfrançais. J'ai déjà entendu ds
miministres fédéraux ne pas être
cacapable de faire des discoursn
frfrançais mais ils essayaient u
momoins. Il ne faisait pas
cecependant qu'il n'était pas
cacapable de prononcer quelques
momots. Cette histoire me semble
tototalement inexacte table.
JuJusqu'au conseil
d'd'administration d'Air Canada,
ququi a jugé bon de nommer ce PG
sasans mettre les critères du
frfrançais comme étant
prprépondérant, je trouve ça trs
ététonnant.
- - Il avait depuis sept ans au
QuQuébec. Ce n'est pas un
amaméricain qu'on est allé
chchercher. Ça aurait pu être le
cacas. Ces emplois, il y a un
mamarché international. Christi,
ququ'est-ce que vous en pensez?
- - Quelle arrogance que les
prprésidents d'Air Canada, une
ininstitution qui est bilingue
seselon la loi, viennent parlerà
MoMontréal juste en anglais.
MoMonsieur Leblanc dit que ça
papasserait mal. Ça ne p passe s
dudu tout. Monsieur Auger a dit
quque celui qui a le plus de
popouvoir dans ce dossier. Ce
n'n'est pas juste ceci Montjoly
BaBarrette et Mélanie Joly.
IlIl n'aurait pas dû l'inviter.l
auaurait dû dire : on s'excuse,n
pepensait que vous parlez
frfrançais. On ne peut pas vous
inviviter si vous ne parlez pas
frfrançais. Il y a des
paparticipants qui font des
prproblèmes demain, ce n'est pas
momoi qui va les prendre parce e
çaça vaut vraiment la peine... n
n'n'est pas pour accepter ça.
UnUne partie des francophones ot
dedes belles paroles, on est por
lele français, mais nos pratiqus
sosont toujours en train de se
cocoucher. C'est totalement
ininacceptable.
- - Je suis allée sur le site de
sasa biographie est née qu'en
ananglais. Il est assumé. C'est
dédésolant quand on voit le prot
dede loi pour protéger la langu.
C'C'est ce que le gouvernement
dodoit compter sur solidaire et
MoMonsieur Rousseau, il n'est ps
llà. Il vit au Québec et c'est
cecertain qu'il n'envoie pas un
sisignal fort aux citoyens.
- - Il y a quelque chose qui fat
191972 dans tout ça. Merci à vos
trtrois, très gentil d'avoir
atattendu, parce que Monsieur
LeLeblanc.